[Musique]
bon
robert hue bonjour bonjour à trois jours
du premier tour force est de constater
qu'il n'y a pas de très social l'ampleur
des grèves et des manifestations de ces
derniers jours montre bien qu'il ya un
très fort besoin de changement une
majorité de français même s'il ne
descendent pas tous dans la rue ne se
résignent pas je voudrais tout de suite
commencer par vous faire écouter une
série de témoignages
moi ce qui m'étonne le plus c'est que ce
qu'ils nous préparent pour après les
élections c'est encore pire et nous
prépare une sélection aggravée j'ai pas
si tu as entendu parler du du rapport
laurent mais s'il était mis en oeuvre il
était mis en oeuvre
ça vous dit ça voudrait dire les droits
d'inscription encore plus important ça
voudrait dire une privatisation de
l'enseignement supérieur est en fait au
final ça veut dire que pour ce conte le
fric pour se payer le luxe d'aller dans
une fac comme celle que pasqua est en
train de construire dans les
hauts-de-seine
trente mille francs l'entrée quand même
eux ils pourront poursuivre leurs études
ya pas de problème
puis pour les autres dans une formation
au rabais à la sortie un petit boulot
peut-être payé 80 % du smic puisque
c'était ça ce qu'on nous promettait avec
le cub3 moi cette société là j'en veux
pas quoi
je m'appelle bernard marquié je suis
chef de service à toulouse matabiau et
il ya 29 ans que je travaille à
senneterre changé oui on a vu arriver
les techniques les plus modernes mais
aussi en même temps le recul du service
public la remise en cause de certains
services de fermetures de gares des
abandons de ligne et surtout pour les
cheminots qui reste le fait qu'on n'est
plus en situation de faire un autre
travail correctement
ça veut dire quoi ça fond les usagers ça
veut dire pour les usagers qu'à côté du
tgv et de certains services
informatiques performants il y à des
endroits où on roule à la même vitesse
qu'il y a trente ans il y a des sections
de lignes où on ne veut toujours pas
plus vite qu'il y a trente ans il y à
aussi manque de matériel qui peut et qui
sont entassés dans des voitures dans des
fringues le soir pour rentrer chez eux
après la journée de travail
et pourtant on nous parle beaucoup de
modernisation voit ici à toulouse métro
automatique depuis deux jours c'est la
preuve que le progrès sur l'utiliser
bien qu on peut faire des choses
intéressantes pour tout le monde mais
malheureusement la sncf
il est confisqué sur les secteurs
rentables et il ne sert qu'à faire de
l'argent par exemple pour monsieur ligne
était gêné c'est l'europe de maastricht
est mal fait il faudrait plutôt adapté
l'europe à la pêche et non pas l'un vers
ce non pas adapter nos moyens
d'existence notre économie à une europe
aujourd'hui par exemple les frontières
sont des passoires et permettent à des
pêcheurs aux pieds nus de venir
concurrencer avec des poissons à vil
prix
le travail et le prix de nos poissons
ici de faire la politique agricole
commune
instaurer les quotas laitiers on nous a
dit diminuer votre production vous aurez
un meilleur prix lorsque le marché
laitier sera assaini le marché laitier
soit disant assainies allez les prix ont
tendance même abaissé actuellement alors
c'est là que je comprends pas pourquoi
on est acceptée le gâte pour qu'on
accepte de diminuer nos exportations
profit des des américains pourquoi tout
ça et de faire disparaître un tas de
notre exploitation
on a on à la dégradation des conditions
d'études maastricht les services publics
tous ne disent pas de la même manière
mais on sent bien que cela ne peut plus
durer
oui ce sont de fortes illustration de
cet immense besoin de changement qui
traverse le pays
ça ne peut plus continuer comme ça il ya
trop de gâchis trop de violence trop
d'inégalités et voyez c est les gens
entassés et ils veulent autre chose et
ils ont raison regarder dans ce
mouvement social actuellement dans le
pays
un fort mouvement pour les salaires pour
les statuts contre la déréglementation
moi je dis à tous ces gens là vous avez
envie d'exprimer quelque chose de fort
et pour vos revendications et bien
saisissez-vous du bulletin de vote
robert hue pour en le mettant dans
l'urne le 23 avril vous ferez avancer
vos revendications
c'était effectivement un vote de
protestation
un vote de lutte en même temps certains
vous reprochent justement de ne pas
suffisamment proposés c'est injuste
c'est vrai que le vote communiste est un
vote qui porte la protestation la
révolte ça c'est vrai mais en même temps
regarder comment il dans la campagne
électorale il s'est montré comme un vote
de propositions de perspectives
pourquoi parce que quand je propose par
exemple d'augmenter de 1000 francs au
moins les salaires lorsque je propose de
réduire à 35 heures sans diminution de
salaire
la semaine hebdomadaire de travail et
bien à chaque fois je dis quelque chose
de majeur jeudi où je vais prendre
l'argent si les autres ne le font pas
moi je dis il faut réorienter l'argent
il faut plus que l'argent irait à la
finance à la boue
mais qu'il aille à l'emploi qui lie à
l'être humain c'est toute la différence
et puis regardez ce ce grand besoin
également de changement qui s'exprime
bien moi je propose qu'il y ait la
construction d'une nouvelle d'une
perspective qui permettent de ne pas se
résigner à la droite est de changer les
choses profondément voulu changer les
choses à gauche oui profondément à
gauche
en axant à gauche en ancrant à gauche
alors justement sur la gauche voudrait
vous faire écouter les témoignages de
d'un député communiste qui se présente
lui-même comme critique est celui d'un
universitaire de bretagne qui dit
pourquoi ils se retrouvent aujourd'hui à
vos côtés après avoir quitté le
particulier je vais quitter par suite
d'un certain nombre de désaccords
parce que je trouvais aussi que la
démocratie interne n est pas tout à fait
satisfaisante
je suis revenu après quelques essais
ailleurs j'aurais gauche mais en me
disant qu'on ne rit j'irai pas
construire un régime progressiste en
france entend des communistes français
que par conséquent ils veulent lui
essayé de changer
plutôt que de jouer à yves élus
communistes j'ai souvent pris des
positions critiques
je mesure chaque jour la tourmente
sociale dans laquelle se trouve plongé
notre pays au robert lutte contre les
méfaits de cette crise lutte contre les
méfaits de maastricht et y luttent pour
un véritable changement
ce combat doit être soutenue au premier
tour
il permettra ainsi une véritable
renaissance de la gauche et robert hue
incarne bien je crois cette espérance
collective
le parti communiste a changé et robert
hue renvoie bien cette image de
changement alors le fait de vous
présenter comme le candidat d'un parti
qui a su tirer les leçons du passé a
certainement participé à créer un élan
autour de votre candidature
votre réaction à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre mais bon je remercie ces deux
personnes de soutien j'y suis sensible
naturellement le parti communiste qui a
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour changer et
va continuer d'en faire pour être mieux
communiste pour être mieux en phase avec
la société mieux au service de notre
peuple
être un parti de dialogue un parti
ouvert dynamique qui permette
effectivement d'aller vers les
changements de société et nécessaire qui
répondant bien au aux préoccupations des
citoyens des gens des jeunes en général
je crois que ces changements voyez-vous
commence à se sentir dans le pignon et
je m'en félicite
vous croyez pas qu'elle se sentirait
encore plus si vous renonciez à vous
appeler communiste parce que c'est très
marqué dans la tête des gens
non mais je ne souhaitons rester
communiste le communisme le mot
communisme c'est un bon mot c'est un mot
qui signifie pour moi qui s'identifient
à partage qui est la communion entre les
hommes à solidarité ce n'a rien à voir
avec la caricature de ce cas ce qui a
échoué à l'est et que j'ai rejeté que
nous rejetons il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui il y a la place pour un
communisme nouveau qui s'inspire de
notre héritage l'héritage du parti
communiste ne date pas de 1920 à
l'héritage communiste ces dix neuvième
siècle c'est la commune de paris c'est
l'héritage de jaurès puis ensuite les
grandes luttes de notre peuple front
populaire la résistance la libération là
les luttes contre les guerres coloniales
c'est ça le parti communiste aujourd'hui
et c'est c'est vrai qu'il ya là un idéal
qui je crois est porteur d'autres le
porte au nom de d'autres valeurs de leur
foi mais moi je respecte ces gens là
mais il y à la voyez-vous dans le
communisme et des propositions concrètes
enfin commence effectivement à se voir
cet élan s'amplifie mais lancement de
plus en plus de
de plus en plus de françaises et de
français ont décidé d'ancrer leur vote à
gauche en votant communiste cette fois
ci alors je voudrais vous faire là
encore écouté le témoignage de madame le
maire de nanterre est juste après celui
d'un enseignant mais cette fois que nous
avons rencontré à toulouse qui dit
pourquoi pour la première fois cette
année il votera communiste en tant que
maire comme l'est d'ailleurs robert hue
lui même
je suis très attentive aux problèmes des
gens des habitants des familles des
jeunes
je peux mesurer concrètement tous les
jours à quel point la situation
s'aggrave et je pense vraiment qu'on ne
peut pas continuer ainsi
il faut arrêter ça ça pose en grand la
question de l'utilisation de la richesse
nationale
est-ce que l'on va continuer à laisser
quelques uns s'accaparer l'essentiel des
moyens de l'argent et tous les autres
vivre dans la difficulté voire dans là
misère pour beaucoup d'entre eux je ne
pense pas je pense qu'il faut examiner
une autre répartition de cette richesse
robert hue est le seul candidat a posé
cette question en grand la question de
l'utilisation de l'argent il est le seul
candidat parmi les candidats de gauche
et pour moi c'est sans doute l'essentiel
de la raison pour laquelle je le
soutiens je soutiens fait vider et puis
robert hue je le connais bien c'est un
homme franc honnête ouvert j'ai des tas
d'autres rêvant de le soutenir pour la
première fois cette année je vais
effectivement voté communiste à une
élection présidentielle
j'avais voté 1981 françois mitterrand
parce que je faisais comme partis comme
des millions de gens ne ceux qui
croyaient pouvoir changer la vie et puis
après avoir analysé un petit peu le
bilan de ses 14 années de pouvoir
j'ai été fortement déçus d'une part par
le
le poids des problèmes économiques qui
se sont aggravées avec le chômage
l'exclusion et la précarité et d'autre
part aussi pour une question morale qui
m'a fait quitter vers le parti
socialiste ou laquelle j'ai adhéré et
qui était la guerre du golfe j'ai
toujours condamné la guerre du golfe et
je me retrouve dans un grand nombre de
propositions de robert hue bon le pour
moi la plus importante étant enseignant
c'est celle qui consiste à enlever
l'argent consacré au surarmement à la
loi de programmation militaire qui est
énorme pour le consacrer à l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire que robert hue
voix l'éducationnationale comme un
investissement
ce qui me séduit tout particulièrement
alors que l'exode candidat particulier
de droite voit le déclin national comme
un coup une charge les français sont en
effet très nombreux à souhaiter que la
gauche soit fidèle à elle même ce
qu'elle doit être
je crois que une progression du parti
communiste le 23 avril va conforter
cette volonté que les valeurs de gauche
soit respecté que qu'une nouvelle puisse
être envisagée construite avec les
citoyens eux-mêmes pour une perspective
politique progressiste dans ce pays et a
donc pas besoin d'être communiste quand
va t on vers une 23 avril non il y avait
beaucoup de communistes qui vont voter
au bureau mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de gens qui ne sont pas communiste et
qui aime se serviront du vote communiste
pour exprimer leur protestation leur
volonté de propositions salariales de
propositions de changement de
perspective et je respecterai leur point
du jeu ne serait pas propriétaire de ce
qu'ils auront mis dans leurs votes
moi je mettrais ce vote au service de
notre peuple tout laisse à penser que la
gauche sera bien présente au second tour
vous c'est ce que la gauche sera
présente au second tour
d'abord parce que la droite a choisi son
son candidat c'est chirac et balladur va
être éliminé la gauche représente la
question donc essentiel c'est le point
que représentera à la fois de la
composante communiste parce que on voit
bien que la droite est en situation de
d'être peut-être élu à la présidence de
république
il faudra bien résisté après il faudra
bien se battre il faudra bien changer
les choses on aura besoin d'un parti
communiste plus fort et plus influents
et ça peut se faire le 23 avril c'est un
élément très important qui peut se
produire
[Musique]